let's talk about Jeff Sessions the
President of the United States in his
increased belligerents over disastrous
news in the Russia investigation went
back on Twitter this morning and slammed
Attorney General Jeff Sessions saying
there would not even be an investigation
right now were it not for the recusal of
Jeff Sessions Trump tweeting the Russian
witch-hunt hoax continues all because
Jeff Sessions didn't tell me he was
going to recuse himself I would have
quickly picked someone else so much time
and money wasted so many lives ruined
and sessions knew better than most that
there was no collusion the real reason
for the investigation according to Trump
is that Jeff Sessions didn't recuse
himself that could only be because you
were planning to use sessions to
obstruct the investigation right and
sessions did the right thing
sessions recused himself because he was
part of the campaign that was being
investigated and he was caught lying to
Al Franken about his contacts with
Russia sessions is not above the law he
recused himself but this is the way that
a scared person acts because the last 24
hours for Trump have been really bad
news and he's in a panic in the last 24
hours we learned that out of those four
million documents that were seized from
Michael Cohen's office and condo and
hotel room I guess almost nothing is
actually privileged we were waiting for
Michael Cohen's lawyers to report back
to investigators which of these
documents contain privileged information
such that they can't be released a
court-appointed watchdog was put out on
this issue and they put out a report
yesterday saying there are almost no
privileged documents whatsoever which
means that it's almost all going to be
turned over to robert muller bad news
for trump number two we learned in the
last 24 hours that the u.s. special
counsel now believes that indicted Trump
campaign Chairman Paul Manafort tried to
tamper with potential witnesses since he
was indicted and put on home confinement
with not one but two GPS tracking
bracelets and men afford according to
investigators has been trying to call
text and send encrypted message
two people from the habsburg group which
was one of his consulting partners for
his ukraine work trying to influence
their testimony and trying to conceal
evidence this is really not good for
Paul Manafort so Trump is imploding he
reacted first of all by canceling the
Philadelphia Eagles visit to the White
House also by going back on Twitter and
just taking it out on Jeff Sessions and
if Jeff Sessions did one thing right in
the last I don't know how long it was
recusing himself from anything Russia
related even though he still remained
involved in some of the firings that
were related to that investigation so
not only with sessions correct to recuse
himself it wasn't even a recusal that he
stuck with yeah it's not a fair critique
by Trump and I think it shows that he
doesn't really understand the concept of
time because Jeff Sessions recused
himself because he perjured himself at
least colloquially during his Senate
confirmation hearing the whole reason he
had a Senate confirmation hearing was
because Trump chose him to be his
attorney general if Trump didn't want
that to happen he would have just chosen
someone who wasn't a part of his
campaign that that's suggesting that
Trump has some personal responsibility
for what took place he's not going to
accept that Trump has never accepted
personal responsibility for anything
whatsoever so a very very bad 24 hours
for Donald Trump the panic is showing
and I would not be surprised if we see I
mean 7 to 10 days more indictments in
Trump Russia I think we've got to be
getting very close at least with some
additional players here so everything is
backwards right the one action sessions
took that would be the correct action
that I can identify over the last year
and a half the one action that Donald
Trump chose to criticize today on
Twitter let's take a quick break we will
be back with much more after this give
us a like on Facebook facebook.com slash
David Pakman show today's program is
made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses which I now have two pairs of
Warby Parker offers a free five day
in-home trial of their glasses you try
five pairs you see which you like I wear
contact lenses on the show but I often
wear glasses at night and on weekends
and both of my pairs of Warby Parker
glasses are great I did the free at-home
trial
I picked five frames that I like
on their website they sent them to me I
pick the one I like the most sent them
back typed in my prescription online and
soon I got my finished glasses with my
prescription in the mail and I love this
because when I'm at a glasses store
trying on glasses I can't really figure
out if I like them because I feel the
pressure of the salespersons gaze on me
I want to show the glasses to other
people I need time to figure out which
glasses I want to commit to and the
eyeglass industry is also controlled by
a tiny number of companies which keeps
prices very high I even know people who
have spent over three hundred dollars
for a pair of glasses but with Warby
Parker there start at just 95 dollars
that's what mine costs to try the five
pairs and support the David Pakman show
go to Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS